[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedrigen sirion ihnen allen guten abend
katja stresow es mit mir im studio katja
viele fußball fans fragen sich gegen wen
muss deutschland bei der wm in katar an
ja das ist spannend in diesen sekunden
werden die gegner ausgelost eins kann
ich schon verraten spanien ist schon mal
dabei wer die anderen beiden sind wissen
wir gleich dann im sportblock wird
spannend unsere wichtigsten nachrichten
jetzt im überblick
vergebliche hoffnung auf hilfe mario
pohl bleibt abgeschnitten konvois mit
nahrung gelangen weiter nicht in die
zerstörte stadt
lebensmittel werden teurer infolge des
krieges in der ukraine kündigen erster
handelsketten kräftige preiserhöhungen
an
die masken dürfen fallen berlin
verzichtet seit heute auf corona
maßnahmen die meisten anderen
bundesländer folgen am wochenende
erstmals wirft russland der ukraine
einen angriff auf das eigene territorium
vor ukrainische hubschrauber sollen im
westen des landes ein treibstofflager
attackiert haben trotzdem verhandeln
beide seiten weiter über eine waffenruhe
besonders dramatisch bleibt die lage im
süden der ukraine wo russische truppen
die stadt mario pohl beschießen und
belagern weitere menschen sollen es
jetzt über einen flucht korridor aus der
stadt geschafft haben mehr jetzt von
axel konrad und saar alaska
endlich raus aus mario pohl endlich in
sicherheit sie sind auf eigene faust
geflohen aus der stadt der ruinen
wir haben glück dass die russen uns
nicht beschossen haben die zwei konvois
vor uns kamen unter feuer und mussten
umkehren
in mario pohl weiter explosionen weiter
beschuss dabei sollte doch ab dem morgen
eigentlich eine waffenruhe gelten damit
es endlich klappt mit der evakuierung
tausender menschen damit dringend
benötigte hilfsgüter in die stadt
gebracht werden können
die busse vom roten kreuz haben sich
trotzdem auf den weg gemacht freie fahrt
zunächst aber die offenbar teuer erkauft
unglücklicherweise haben die besatzer
die humanitären hilfsgütern an sich
genommen 14 tonnen essen und medizin das
war der preis für die vereinbarung mit
dem roten kreuz für einen flucht
korridor
auch heute im norden bleibt unter
heftigem russischen beschuss einige
trauen sich in den feuerpausen raus
rollen auf suche nach verwertbaren am
sichersten aber ist es ganz tief unter
der erde hier haust svetlana mit ihrer
achtjährigen tochter anastasia seit
kriegsbeginn in diesem u bahnwaggon 20
meter unter der stadt kein tageslicht
seit einem monat aber tief genug um den
krieg wenigstens nicht zu hören
hier ist es noch sicherer in den gängen
über uns da hört man die bomben für
unsere psyche ist es hier unten besser
mein leben es gut hier mit all den
tieren aber ich träume davon dass
technik bald vorbei ist und die ukraine
gewinnt
und dann gibt es auch diese kurzen
momente der unbeschwertheit sie haben
eine show für die kleinen organisiert
ablenkung vom grauen überlingen
und ganz in der nähe in belgorod auf
russischer seite erleben sie den krieg
im nachbarland plötzlich hautnah
zweikampf hubschrauber im tiefflug das
berichten die russen hätten ein
treibstofflager angegriffen und einen
großbrand ausgelöst
die russischen kräfte ihn jetzt in ihrer
vor und barsten phase man versucht eben
deshalb munition und treibstoff zu
treffen damit die verwundbare phase
möglichst lang anhält die ukrainische
seite will den angriff nicht
kommentieren wir sind nicht für jede
katastrophe auf russischem gebiet
verantwortlich heißt es lapidar
fragen wir nach ball christian seinem in
moskau christian was hat es mit diesem
mutmaßlichen angriff auf sich
ja da sind tatsächlich noch viele fragen
offen jetzt am abend eine stunde vor der
sendung hat sich der sprecher des
russischen verteidigungsministeriums zu
dem vorfall geäußert und gesagt diese 2
mi 24 kampfhubschrauber die hätten in
extrem niedriger höhe die grenze
überquert und dann dieses depot
geschossen unabhängig überprüfen lässt
sich das nicht über den tag hat er sich
kreml sprecher paskov auch dazu geäußert
und gesagt dieser zwischenfall der
überschatte rinn natürlich die
friedensgespräche die zwischen der
ukraine und russland stattfinden was
genau da stattgefunden hat das werden
wir vielleicht in den nächsten tagen
noch sehen aber insgesamt können wir
sagen dass natürlich bei solchen
zwischenfällen
die sorge wächst dass russland das zum
anlass nehmen könnte die militärische
aktivität in der ukraine zu erhöhen
vielen dank für diese hintergründe nach
moskau christiansen in diesen
kriegszeiten ist man entweder für oder
gegen putin fast alle mächtigen staaten
versuchen moskau zu sanktionieren und
isolieren aus china zwar fürchtet peking
wirtschaftliche konsequenzen aber den
russischen angriffskrieg verurteilen
will man nicht bei einem gipfeltreffen
mit der chinesischen führung versuchte
die eu heute einfluss zu nehmen und
warnte china vor mehr unterstützt für
russland florian neumann berichtet
dass die kommissionspräsidentin nicht
zurück winkt mag ein versehen sein weil
sie gerade nicht auf den monitor blickt
aber es passt zum eisigen verhältnis
zwischen eu und china da schalten sich
zwei weltmächte zusammen die sich nur
noch wirtschaftlich blendend versteht
heute war definitiv kein gewöhnlicher
gipfel er fand in der nüchterne
atmosphäre statt vor dem hintergrund des
russischen krieges gegen die ukraine
und vor dem hintergrund einer neuen
allianz gegen den westen die russland
und china bereits vor beginn des
russischen krieges geschmiedet hatten
seitdem kein kritisches wort chinas
gegen den russischen angriff aber auch
keine offene etwa militärische
unterstützung was die eu als ihre rote
linie definiert
wir hoffen dass unsere argumente die wir
mit nachdruck vorgebracht haben von der
chinesischen seite gehört werden wir
hoffen dass china dabei auch an sein
internationales ansehen denkt und an die
wirtschaftsbeziehungen zwischen china
und der europäischen union
die nämlich werden trotz politischer
eiszeit immer intensiver pro tag allein
handeln eu und china waren im wert von
1,9 milliarden euro sollte 2020 ist
china vor den usa der wichtigste
handelspartner der eu statt auf
sanktionen setzt europa deshalb auf die
kraft der argumente und hofft dass china
abrückt von russland das aber ist nach
dem gipfel von heute nicht zu erkennen
gewehr zu ulf röller nach peking auf die
eu warnt china vor der unterstützung
moskaus was kann was darf europa von
china jetzt erwarten
ich glaube europa kann erwarten dass
china die sanktionen die gegen russland
verengt sind nicht unter läuft da wird
peking sehr genau darauf achten aus
einem ganz einfachen grund es ist ein
großes interesse für peking weiter eine
engere wirtschaftsbeziehungen mit europa
aufrecht zu erhalten man fürchtet wenn
man diese sanktion unterlaufen würde
gegen europa dass man dann selber
sanktioniert wird wird und nun hat kein
interesse in peking an einem
handelskrieg mit europa europa kann
allerdings nicht von china erwarten dass
es sich politisch loslässt loslöst vor
russland im gegenteil präsident ski
sieht die welt eigentlich aufgeteilt in
diese zwei blöcke auf der einen seite
das westliche bündnis und amerika und
auf der anderen seite eben russland und
china und china als führungs nation dort
präsident wird weiter versuchen einen
keil uns langfristig zwischen europa und
amerika zu treiben um dieses festliche
bündnis zu sprechen also insofern hat
dieser gipfel heute auch gezeigt die
widersprüchlichkeit dieser neuen
weltordnung china will einerseits europa
politisch bekämpfen andererseits die
abhängigkeiten erhöht und man hat ja
gesehen wie gefährlich es ist wenn eben
abhängigkeiten mit diktaturen bestehen
besten dank für die analyse ulf röller
war das in peking mehr als vier
millionen menschen sind schon aus der
ukraine geflohen die meisten nach polen
viele auch nach deutschland wie viele
das weiß niemand genau registriert sind
bis jetzt fast
295.000 geflüchtete eine pflicht das zu
tun gibt es erst nach 90 tagen so lange
können sie sich ohne visum in der eu
aufhalten die kommunen wollen von
kanzler scholz mehr klarheit wie die
menschen im land schneller und gerecht
verteilt werden können dazu andrea
maurer
seit der flucht ist diese ukrainische
familie noch immer nirgendwo angekommen
sie waren in paris jetzt wollen sie
weiter wohin wissen sie noch nicht genau
eine irrfahrt der bahnhof mannheim
durchgangsstation nacho handel hat schon
in der flüchtlingskrise 2015
ehrenamtlich geholfen ihr fehlt heute
die staatliche steuerung
also
2015/16 da gab es
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen die waren alle
einigermaßen relativ vorbereitet oder
man hat auch während der
der einreise der geflüchteten diese
strukturen aufgebaut aber jetzt merke
ich gar nichts davon wer ist zuständig
wie können die geflüchteten schneller
registriert besser verteilt werden
treffen der kommunalen spitzenverbände
heute mit kanzler ministerinnen und
ministern was konkret zu machen wir
haben in leipzig aktuell etwa acht bis
zehntausend menschen aus der ukraine die
einen erste aufnahme an einrichtungen
die anderen in privaten wohnungen sie zu
registrieren das zu bewältigen das wird
eine riesige herausforderung
eine generelle registrierung der
geflüchteten bei der einreise lehnt die
innenministerin bislang ab erschöpften
flüchtlingen sollen keine
grenzkontrollen zugemutet werden der
koalitionspartner fdp sieht das anders
ebenso die union ich würde eine
regierung alle flüchtlinge für besser
halten weil wir dann genau wüssten wie
viele menschen kommen wer kommt um sie
bedarfsgerecht versorgen zu können die
bundesregierung hat das problem zu
beginn unterschätzt weil sie auf eine
registrierung der angekommenen
verzichtet hat und das ist aber eine
ganz entscheidende voraussetzung die
länder und kommunen müssten ja wissen
für wie viele menschen sie
beispielsweise die unterbringung zu
gewährleisten haben politisch geht es
nun auch um die frage wer die kosten für
die aufnahme übernimmt die länder
fordern vom bund hilfe in milliardenhöhe
der bund will helfen aber verhandelt
noch über den umfang
jedenfalls gehört wenig phantasie dazu
sich vorzustellen dass sehr viele
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer weiterhin
jede menge hilfe benötigen und so ging
es über das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine und alles
zum nachlesen für sie auch unter spenden
punkt zdf.de und auf der zdf textseite
immer stärker ist der ukraine krieg ja
jetzt auch im deutschen alltag zu spüren
und zwar nicht nur beim tanken oder
heizen lebensmittel verteuern sich
rasant
ein grund die hersteller müssen etwa für
weizen tierfutter und energie deutlich
mehr geld bezahlen das kommt jetzt in
den supermärkten an mit aufschlägen von
20 bis 5 auf einzelne produkte rechnet
die branche am montag legt aldi vor aber
fast alle anderen ketten planen
nachzuziehen thomas münten berichtet
es gibt keine schlangen vor den aldi
märkten in deutschland heute ganz
normaler betrieb vor einem wochenende
ab montag werden beide aldi ketten vor
allem die preise für fleisch wurst und
milcherzeugnisse deutlich anheben bis zu
30 prozent könnte zb butter teurer
werden die verbraucher besorgt und
ratlos
leider nicht so viel und ja das ist für
mich natürlich ungünstig und ich würde
es mir anders wünschen das hat ja alles
ursachen und von daher
muss man damit wohl leben können der
discount riese geht voraus aber das ist
schon klar die anderen
lebensmittelhändler werden folgen müssen
ob rewe penny edeka netto oder lidl
es ist kein thema der discounter sind
das wird alle anderen supermärkte und
andere geschäfte auch mit betreffen und
für die verbraucher heißt das natürlich
dass sie sich darauf einstellen müssen
und typischerweise schlechter ist das
verbrauchervertrauen das heißt jetzt
kann auch noch mal dazu führen dass
bestimmte anschaffungen getätigt werden
den verdacht dass die händler den
gestiegenen preisen mehr verdienen weiß
der verband klar zurück
in der tat tut der handel alles und wird
auch einen entsprechenden preis
forderung der industrie genau prüfen
aber leider sind wir momentan auch nicht
in der lage diese kostenerhöhung selber
aufzufangen sondern müssen es weiter
geben über die preise an den interview
bis die lebensmittelpreise wieder sinken
kann es nach schätzungen des institutes
der deutschen wirtschaft durchaus länger
dauern
mitten im ukraine kriegt diese meldung
ein ex reserveoffizier der bundeswehr
und wirtschaftsvertreter soll für einen
russischen nachrichtendienst spioniert
haben der vorwurf sechs jahre lieferte
ralf g russland wohl brisante
kontaktdaten wie auch informationen zu
nord stream 2 jetzt hat die
bundesanwaltschaft anklage erhoben wegen
spionage für russland
für rund 300 deutsche soldatinnen und
soldaten heißt es bald ab nach hause
ende des monats endet das mandat für die
eu mission atalanta seit 2008 war die
marine am horn von afrika stationiert
und halte unter anderem mit piraten
angriffe abzuwehren die gab es in der
region zeitweise hundertfach pro jahr
fanden zuletzt aber überhaupt nicht mehr
statt
die derzeitige corona welle hat ihren
höhepunkt nach einschätzung des robert
koch institutes möglicherweise schon
überschritten insbesondere bei jüngeren
zwischen 15 und 34 sei die incident so
rückläufig bei den über 60 jährigen
steige sie jedoch wieder an heute meldet
das lka 252 1530 neuinfektionen
innerhalb eines tages
1968 weniger als vor einer woche
außerdem kamen 300 vier todesfälle hinzu
die sieben tage incidents sinkt auf
1.506 und 80,4
die masken sie gehören für uns
inzwischen zum alltag jetzt am sonntag
fallen sie in fast allen bereichen und
fast allen bundesländern wie auch sonst
eigentlich die ganzen kroner maßnahmen
in berlin ging es schon heute los und
wie es dort lief in der hauptstadt das
erzählt uns jetzt romanesco war keine
masken pflicht mehr in der ständigen
vertretung seit heute setzt das berliner
restaurant auf freiwilligkeit für gäste
wie personal der chef ist froh keine 3g
kontrollen mehr keine diskussionen als
vorstandsmitglied des berliner
gaststättenverbandes schätzt er aber
dass nicht alle betriebe so reagieren
also ich so höre ist so eine 50 50 also
ein teil will weiter in einer maske
nicht festhalten anderer teil nicht
kommt sicherlich auch auf die art der
gastronomie an komplett festhalten an
der masken pflicht wollen die
staatlichen museen mit hilfe des
hausrechts auch in der neuen
nationalgalerie heißt es daher weiter
zutritt nur mit mund nasenschutz das
soll auch helfen personelle engpässe zu
vermeiden die entscheidung ist wirklich
wir wollen sehen dass unsere kolleginnen
und kollegen die hier im haus arbeiten
möglich sicher sind weil diese den
ganzen tag hier und das wir stetig offen
sein können diffus die lage im
einzelhandel rund um den kudamm gibt es
jetzt geschäfte mit masken pflicht und
welche ohne manche setzen auf
freiwilligkeit anderer achten nur darauf
dass es nicht zu voll wird egal was gilt
viele behielten die masken auf heute zu
den lockerungen gehen die meinungen
auseinander
es seien werde noch mal und das schöne
das gefährt in zahlen nach zu urteilen
ist es viel zu früh ich werde weiter
meine maske tragen einfach aus
gewohnheit mittlerweile schon glaube das
hat zwei jahre lang diese masken pflicht
und auch einfach auf sicherheit eine
hotspot regel wie in anderen
bundesländern wird es in berlin vorerst
nicht geben heißt es aus der politik die
korona lage gebe dass derzeit nicht her
ja ab sonntag also greifen die neuen
regeln was genau dann wo erlaubt es das
können sie in unserer heute nachlesen
vom supermarkt bis zum restaurant und
wir haben auch aufgelistet was in den
bundesländern gilt die sich zu hot spots
erklärt haben wir verlassen die erde
gehen ins all denn dort ist jetzt ein
weiterer deutscher satellit es vor gut
einer halben stunde mit einer space
extrakte in florida abgehoben ziel des
satelliten programms ist die bessere
erkundung der erdöl ko-system mehr zum
raketenstart und dem vorhaben von
brigitte sah
im lift off cape canaveral in florida an
bord einer space extrakte geht es ins
all noch haben sie keinen kontakt zu dem
satelliten mit dem namen m ab der dann
erst mal ausgerichtet werden muss
20 uhr über unsere erste antennen
station fliegen die ist in norwegen in
spitzbergen und von dem moment an hat
unser team alle hände voll zu tun das
besondere an dem satelliten mit dem
namen ändert er kann neben dem
sichtbaren bereich des lichts auch
besonders viele frequenz kanäle im
infrarotbereich auswerten die
detaillierte daten von der
beschaffenheit der erdoberfläche liefern
wir haben die möglichkeit in 27 tagen
immer wieder über den gleichen ort
rüberzukommen das heißt es erlaubt uns
tatsächlich zeitreihen
aufzunehmen und daraus trends abzulesen
es geht darum großflächige veränderungen
der umwelt zu beobachten der satellit
kann zum beispiel die wasserqualität von
gewässern bestimmen messen in welchem
zustand wälder oder anbauflächen sind
und erkennen wie viel feuchtigkeit im
boden steckt wo kommt das wasser her wo
geht das wasser hin warum geht es dahin
und auf einmal nicht mehr dahin da haben
wir die dürren da haben wir die
überschwemmung auswirkungen des
klimawandels auf die umwelt fünf jahre
lang sollen wissenschaftler aus aller
welt durch ein map jetzt neue
detaillierte daten zum klimawandel auf
der erde bekommen
der norden hat sein winter comeback ja
gestern schon gegeben jetzt zog das
schneetief über ganz deutschland bis
nach bayern über zehn zentimeter
neuschnee konnten es heute sein und so
mancher autofahrer waren darauf nicht
eingestellt es gab etliche
verkehrsunfälle mindestens bis sonntag
soll es winterlich bleiben der frühling
muss sich also noch ein bisschen
gedulden
schnee gehört zum winter winter nicht
unbedingt zu einer fußball-wm und doch
wird so kommen zumindest aus unserer
perspektive und wir erfahren jetzt mehr
über die gruppengegner deutschland es
wurde ausgelost für die wm die erste wm
im winter in katar das eröffnungsspiel
findet am 21 november statt das finale
kurz vor weihnachten am 18 dezember und
bei einer farbenfrohen gala wurden eben
gerade die gruppen ausgelost und
deutschland spielt in gruppe e gegen
spanien japan und gegen den sieger des
playoff spiels costa rica gegen
neuseeland markus harm ist live für uns
in doha markus wie sind die zugelosten
gegner einzuschätzen
ja man kann sagen im dfb ist das
losglück treu geblieben die gruppe ist
relativ einfach nach meiner einschätzung
das deutsche auftaktspiel am 23.11
findet gegen japan statt das zweite
spiel und das ist dann das schwierigste
gegen spanien das ist eine wiederauflage
des wm halbfinales von 2010 spanien
weltmeister 2010 europameister 2008 also
das ist schon ein harter brocken und
dann zuletzt noch gegen neuseeland oder
costa rica das wird noch ausgespielt
dieses spiel aber dennoch
ein weiterkommen denke ich sollte drin
sein für die deutsche mannschaft nur
spanien ist ein wirklich richtig ernst
zu nehmender gegner stehen dankbar kurs
alle gruppen dann auch im internet bei
uns unter zdf.de jetzt zum frauenfußball
die spielerinnen des vfl wolfsburg
gehören seit gestern abend zu den vier
top teams in europa sie besiegten im
viertelfinal-rückspiel die frauen von
arsenal london mit 2 zu 0
jubel bei den spielerinnen und ein
glückliches trainerteam wolfsburg
vollkommen verdient im
champions-league-halbfinale führung in
der neunten minute durch rot die den
ball vorbei spitzeln zinsberger die
entscheidung dann in der zweiten
halbzeit 73 minute williams mit dem
eigentor wolfsburg trifft jetzt auf die
beste frauen fußballmannschaft der welt
freuen uns jetzt auf barcelona auf die
nächste runde hier im stadion
wahrscheinlich unter dann hoffentlich
weiter es sind die wochen der wahrheit
für wolfsburg in der bundesliga wartet
am sonntag der fc bayern
und in der bundesliga der männer heißt
das spitzenspiel morgen abend borussia
dortmund gegen rb leipzig der bvb will
den anschluss an die bayern die momentan
mit sechs punkten vorsprung die tabelle
anführen nicht verlieren und hofft auf
den einsatz seines spitzen stürmers kann
dortmunds torjäger er in holon trotz
lädierten knöchels spielen gegen leipzig
im erstmals seit mehr als zwei jahren
voll besetzten heimischen stadion
reichte
natürlich unbedingt aber wir müssen
morgen heute morgen einfach schauen wie
sich die dinge entwickeln ein
verblüffend klares daumen hoch für
holland dagegen vom gegnerischen trainer
wir planen dass er spielt wieder wird
auch spielen womit umgehen das topspiel
nicht nur für uns auch für sie und da
wird alles daran gesetzt dass er spielt
und er wird spielen musik in den ohren
aller bvb-fans mit roland und
ohrenbetäubenden fans im rücken wäre
dortmund gegen leipzig favorit
und die ersten bilder dieses spiels im
free-tv morgen mit einem aktuellen
sportstudio vielen bank katja zum wetter
so viel der schneefall ist noch nicht
vorbei mehr details gleich von katja
horneffer um 22 uhr empfehle ich ihnen
das heute journal mit christian sievers
von uns war es dass wir von heute 19
team danken fis interesse wünschen einen
entspannten start ins wochenende schönen
abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend das schneetief lotte brachte
heute verbreitet zwischen zwei und zwölf
zentimeter schnee allerdings ist der
regen noch nicht überall in schnee
übergegangen hier im süden da ist es
derzeit noch regen das wird sich aber in
der nacht ändern dann geht der regen
auch dort in schnee über machen sie sich
also auf fünf bis 15 zentimeter
neuschnee gefasst es wird glatt auf
straßen und auf gehwegen im osten und
dem nordosten dagegen kommt kein schnee
mehr runter dazu pfeift immer noch ein
böiger wind aus nord nordöstlichen
richtungen die temperaturen sinken auf
plus 2 bis minus fünf grad und morgen
bleibt es in der südhälfte kalt mit
temperaturen um den gefrierpunkt milder
wird es im norden mit fünf bis acht grad
denn dort reißen die wolken auseinander
und sie sehen häufig die sonne im süden
sieht anders aus dem saarland rheinland
pfalz in baden-württemberg und bayern da
schneit es vor allen dingen am vormittag
noch kräftig weiter im laufe des tages
ziehen sich die schneefälle an den
alpenrand zurück und am sonntag wird es
freundlich und frisch bei temperaturen
von zwei bis zehn grad dann kommen neue
regenwolken von nordwesten heran guten
abend